brand-new study on the corona virus
shedding light on just how long the
virus can live on surfaces scientists
now discovering that it can remain
detectable for several hours or even
days in some cases William la jeunesse
is live in Los Angeles with what we need
to know he William Sandra you don't want
to get this or give it to others here's
what the government study found on the
corona virus say a person sneezes or
coughs the virus stays airborne for
about 30 minutes at high levels but
detectable for three hours before the
aerosol droplets fall onto surfaces
where it can survive in cardboard up to
24 hours stainless steel two days
plastic for three hard surfaces not
shown in fabric as much or in cardboard
but hard surfaces transmission the virus
remains communicable but the risk
declines over that time frame as it dies
off the take away be careful at home and
the public especially if someone is
infected people should recognize that
living with this thing means that
there's a 35% attack rate that is chance
that someone else in the house gets the
virus because one person in the house
has it best practice keep everything
cleaned faucets hand railings door
handles refrigerator microwave TV remote
and countertops use long strokes and
wipe in only one direction
most people grab a towel and they move
in multiple directions and they're
actually pushing and pulling soil back
onto a surface think about pushing snow
if you will you're always plowing in one
direction but do the same thing when
you're wiping off the counter so in
public yes dollars bills coins credit
cards carry bacterial pathogens gas
bunks ATM elevator buttons you get that
picture
Sandra basically soap and water
commercial disinfected boom back to you
yes there's so many questions that
people have about that William la
jeunesse thank you